lorsque le premier chemin de fer pour
voyageurs a été inventé en France
c'était entre Paris et Saint-Germain en
lait attention départ imminent l'Office
de Tourisme de Saint-Germain boucle de
scène vous embarque pour une visite
commentée à bord du nouveau tramou T13
c'est une visite qui relie deux grands
domaines historiques qui fait la part
belle aussi aux écomobilités c'est bien
d'expliquer à ceux qui utilisent le tram
pourquoi il est là de c'est pas une un
hasard Saint-Germain c'est vraiment le
résultat d'une très vieille histoire
liée au transport depuis le 19e siècle
et puis c'est aussi le but de se dire
qu'on prend pas le tram juste pour être
dans le tram mais qu'il y a des choses à
voir à gauche et à droite et ça peut
être des suggestion de visite des
suggestions de visite comme l'école
militaire de saint-sirlécole la forêt de
Marly ou encore les vergers de l'étant
la ville installé confortablement dans
le tram vous découvrirez l'histoire et
le patrimoine des villes
on voit bien les vergers dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure il a vraiment
situé ça dans les
vergers nous avons eu un superbe guide
qui nous a très bien commenté on a
appris beaucoup de choses de
connaissance super franchement très la
guide est très très compétente
franchement on a on a appris plein de
choses quoi que je peux pas dire là
parce que j'ai oublié mais B c'est
vraiment bien vous en saurez également
plus sur l'histoire de ces rail qui date
de 1837 comp environ 1hure de de visite
et 12 € par personne sans le titre de
transport prochaine visite le 4 mai à
11h ou
14h30